[Music]
thank you
how's everybody doing financially I make
eleven thousand dollars a year which is
not a good amount if you're familiar
with money here's how I know it's not
the government doesn't make me pay taxes
yeah basically they're like Gary you
keep it you need more than we do and the
government's right there right I need
money but I've reached the age where I
can't ask my parents for money
I want to ask them but I can't ask that
cuz they told me not to ask them anymore
that's why instead I sent them the
nicest letter dear mr. and mrs. veter we
have your son
[Applause]
if you want to see him again please
deposit $60 into his checking account I
used to be a receptionist that was my
old gig but I got fired from being a
receptionist all that happened all that
got me fired was I transferred a call
that came in to this woman Robin in the
office but I flubbed it this was the
call hi Robin its Gary over at reception
I have your mom on the line she goes my
mom passed away eight years ago I was
like then you might want to take this
I'm single
[Music]
my parents tried setting me up with a
girl don't do that don't have your
parents play matchmaker this is how the
describer Gary she's perfect she's the
girl version of you
[Music]
girl version of me I'm five six 140
pounds I suck at sports I am the girl
version I travel a lot which makes being
a relationship difficult one time I was
on the road this girl I was seeing sent
me topless photos she was like what do
you think I was like I like them that
didn't sit well with her she was like
you only like that I was like sweetie if
it makes you feel any better my friends
love them
I'm Jewish
they're perks to being Jewish there are
I gotta go Israel for free that's a good
perk there's a program that sends Jewish
people to Israel for free but before
they sent just anyone they put you
through a screening process to make sure
you're Jewish and they'll ask you
questions first question they asked me
are you Jewish I was like I'm trying to
get a free trip aren't I
they were like no further questions
[Applause]